-Hey, everyone, it is Nana Week.
And my new children's book,
"Nana Loves You More,"
is out today!
It's pub day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It is -- They call --
They call it "pub day."
-"Pub day."
-Publishing day.
-Oh.
-And it's called pub day.
It's a little
inside business -- Yeah.
-So you go to a pub.
-I went to a pub and got
smashed, today, yeah.
-Yeah.
-No, I got a lot of
"Happy pub day,"
and that's what it means.
-Oh.
-Publishing. Yeah.
Do you want me
to read you a page?
-Please.
-Which one?
-Not the super-sad one.
I don't want to cry.
-No, there's only one kind of
little sad one in there.
But it's not that sad.
-Read that one.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Whew!
You picked a good one.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-"More than gold
or treasure or money?
"You are my treasure.
You are my honey."
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh!
-Whew!
-Snap!
-Anyway, that's just one of
the memories you'll make
when you read this.
-And it's $16,000?
-$16,000, yes.
-Wow!
-In crypto bucks.
-Oh, crypto bucks.
-Yeah.
You play 30 Jimmy Coin for this,
and you get --
It's only worth --
It's like 4 Ethereum.
You get --
You get 30 Jimmy Coin.
-Right. Some Ape Coin.
-Yep, you get Ape Coin,
of course.
Obviously, Doge Dollar.
You get --
-Kohl's Cash.
-Yep.
You get, uh -- Yeah.
Desk Coin. You can get that.
You trade in that.
You got to wait a week.
-You got to wait a week
or else it transforms.
-Oh, it's going to go down.
You lose all your money.
If you buy this now,
it'll go down.
I would wait a week,
then buy this.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And then...
[ Whistles ]
-Yeah, then --
-Then sell it again.
-Yeah, as an NFT.
-As an NFT.
-Right.
-Then buy it back
with the American dollar.
-Yeah.
-Sell it for gas money.
-So, all week long,
we're giving some love
to all the grandmas out there,
all the nanas,
all the gam-gams, all meemaws.
Yeah, all the nonnas.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Abuelas!
-The abuelas in the world.
Without you, what would we be?
We love you.
And to show you
how much we love you,
each night this week,
we're shining a spotlight on
a talented grandma on our show.
So, tonight's nana is
Dorothea Taylor.
She is 71 years old
and she's from
Myrtle Beach, South Carolina.
And tonight, she's going to
play the drums for us.
Come on out here, Dorothea.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you so much
for being here.
Dorothea,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you so much
for being here.
I know you have three children.
How many grandkids do you have?
-I have two grandchildren --
one 13, who's going to be
a musician, too,
and an 8-month-old.
-Oh, come on.
Well, you're gonna love
that book.
-Brand-new.
-Congratulations.
You're going to play
the drums for us,
but I heard that you had
a special request.
-I would love to have
a drum-off with Questlove.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-A drum-off with Questlove.
Now we're talking!
Are these drums
perfectly fine for you here?
-These are perfectly fine.
I have a kit just like this at
home that I gig out with.
-Yeah. Perfect.
Then why don't you get up there,
get ready to go.
We're gonna start this drum-off.
Can I do anything for you?
♪♪
How long have you been
playing the drums?
-58 years.
-Hey!
That's what I'm talking about.
I think you know what's up.
Quest, you better bring -- You
better bring your A-game, buddy.
-I hope so.
I've only been playing for
58 months.
[ Laughter ]
-Dorothea, whenever you're
ready, let the drum-off begin.
-Okay.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
Yes! [ Laughs ]
Yeah!
[ Laughs ]
Come -- Just...
Just don't even.
Yeah, that's right, yeah.
Dorothea, wait.
I have an idea
for this last one.
That was amazing, by the way.
For this last one, how about
something that Questlove himself
had a little trouble
doing when --
-Phil?
-Phil Collins --
-Ah, man, come on!
-Phil Collins was on the show,
and we really hyped up that solo
from "In the Air Tonight,"
the...
[ Imitating drum fill ]
And then when Phil came on to
play it with us and Quest,
I just kind of snuck around
and stared at Quest for like --
-You startled me
right at that moment.
-Can you -- What do you think?
Can you do the
classic drum solo from
"In the Air Tonight,"
Phil Collins?
-I'll try it.
-Okay, buddy.
-Okay.
-Alright, Dorothea.
That's it! That's how you do it!
♪♪
That's right!
Give it up for
Dorothea Taylor, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
Come on back.
♪♪